hallöchen freuen und herzlich willkommen
zu einem weiteren iphone-spiel video
nachdem ich das letzte mal gemacht
meinten viele leute ich soll doch mal
ein mailing steve ausprobieren und das
werde ich jetzt hier mal eine runde
zocken ich würd sagen wir fangen direkt
an so sieht das ganze halt aus ihr seht
es wahrscheinlich gerade schon
eingeblendete steht allerdings von unten
diese scheiß google werbung wie kriegt
im stadtpark mit bilder vom gebot so
sieht das ganze aus so funktioniert das
ganze wir können einmal klicken dann
springen wir und doppelklicken machen
wir so eine doppelte rolle und wir
müssen quasi einfach durch diesen
parcours hier durch meine high schools 1
da seht ihr das score 1 best 1 also ich
bin da drinnen auf jeden fall richtig
gut aber wir wollen das ganze natürlich
locker angehen wir kaum grün das ist
unsere farbe grün ist doch das ist doch
dass das ding ich setze mir als ziel
heute irgendwie das war unmöglich zu
schaffen wie soll man denn so etwas
hinkriegen mein ziel ist dass ich heute
irgendwo wollen nämlich kommen da nicht
hin zum viel google in einer kleinen app
von google die götter youtube von daher
machen wir gehen das ganze jetzt mal ein
bisschen lockerer anders die 123 aber
hey freunde wir haben jetzt schon mal
eine 3
dieses spiel ist ein bisschen wie
blackbird da mag es macht extrem süchtig
ist vor es ist von ketchup und die haben
so ein paar andere spieler auch noch
gemacht die haben amazing brig glaub ich
aufgemacht wo wahrscheinlich ne 3 ich
war kurz davor die vier zu sagen und
dann ich weiß halt auch nicht was diese
ganze app ich weiß auch nicht was er
wollte sagen ich weiß auch nicht was
diese ganze app überhaupt mit einem tief
zu tun hat also die spiel regie steve
also
das spiel heißt macy fall so
unglaublicher oder atemberaubender dieb
oder einzigartiger dieb oder sowas und
das einzige was hier ist es ein kleines
männchen was durch bunte tore durch
läuft also ich weiß das nicht was das
irgendwie mit wie soll man da denn
packen mein ziel etwas zweistelliges zu
schaffen ist eventuell ein bisschen zu
hoch angesiedelt einfach ruhig bleiben
freunde wenn jetzt einfach ruhig bleiben
dann werden wir das ganze schon irgend
wissen wenn man einmal drückt kann man
es auch nicht mehr rückgängig machen
kann ich irgendwie besonders stark
drückt man drückt quasi einmal und dann
springt er auch so man lässt es kann
doch nicht sein dass jetzt haben wir ja
auch noch die ampelfarben rot grün
ich scheiß auf euren flow mag ich bin 1
mit dem spiel 1
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein
irgendwie kleiner junge das kann doch
nicht sein dass ich nicht mehr als ich
finde wir sollten offen uns irgendwelche
unrealistischen ziele zu setzen wir
machen das ganze jetzt einfach mal weil
die app und spaß macht ja so eine tolle
app ohne spaß ich nehme jetzt mal am cut
auf bis ich einen neuen highscore
irgendwie geschafft habe ich setze jetzt
keine katze bissig mehr als vier
geschafft habe mit dem er sich dass ich
mich bewegt ein bisschen
da kommen aber auch solche behinderten
levels wie soll man denn so was schaffen
meine fresse das wie soll wie soll ich
denn so ein sprung ich kann doch gar
nicht ab messen wie viel der runter und
dann und blauen block man man man
so jetzt jetzt jetzt habe ich ihn
ich kann den sprung schaffen mann ich
weiß ich wollte keine kraft setzen aber
das kann doch nicht wahr sein
es ist 4 werde eins mit dem spiel luca 1
vielleicht braucht man halt einfach den
gewissen zweck das ganze ja so ein
bisschen besser zu bestehen ich habe
irgendwie im gefühl dass das jetzt unser
level will ich bin ich weiß nicht was
jetzt als nächstes kommt aber ich glaube
ich mein gott ich hab's geschafft
okay zwei media markt das kann doch
nicht so schwer sein dass ich mal
irgendwie beim ein high score von 4,9
ihm ähnlich gut gemeint euer spiel nicht
will
ich muss das doch jetzt mal irgendwie
schaffen hier so einen verdammten
highschool zu erzielen
ich glaube das wird mir richtig gut
vielleicht dürft ihr mich auch einfach
nicht sehen das könnte auch eventuell
die lösung sein dass einfach meine
visage aber es hat eigentlich ja schon
mal ganz gut geklappt also ich muss
sagen ich will mich da nicht darüber
beschweren es ist natürlich jetzt haben
wir den absoluten zeigt das heißt wir
müssen jetzt auf jeden fall irgendetwas
reißen was im dreistelligen bereich
wahrscheinlich als ich mein ich habe
drei kappen auf steht für freunde die
das unternehmen steht für uns die räume
ich gebe mir einen letzten versuch wenn
ich jetzt mehr als vier shuffle da kommt
danach eine vernünftige verabschiedung
und wenn ich weniger als vier schaffe
dann ist das passiert nicht das kann
doch nicht verhindert sondern verdammt
ich nehme das nur jakob das ist doch mal
ein cooler anfangen kann man doch mal
nehmen so 2